and they'll be hosting the indiana  pacers later tonight oh come on shot  that's hockey chuck that's how i cleaned  my glasses  to clean your glasses you got one of  those things too yeah i had to get it  wet first  that's what  that's how i cleaned my glasses  well you've got that underdog put that  on the nft that's why that's why they  give you that little cloth because it'll  clean it without any moisture on it man  no  [Laughter]  i need to be able to see man it's more  important to me to see to worry about  hygiene i know  oh man all right um anyway eight points  i can't do anything without y'all  filming it well  got the lead over here with 18 cameras  here  like that  like that nikki